do you know do you know why he said  always such a bumpy london on ryanair  huh because they found a loophole right  now he's found a loophole you land  faster than anybody else oh god  you're flying  stop shouting for two seconds ladle and  we're gonna blend the soup the lid he's  off the lid  okay now use a ladle okay to help aid  yeah okay the soup into the blender now  at this point please be very careful  okay we're gonna place  it's very  it's very very hot  now  johnny johnny yes i'm gonna put it in on  the end of your mixer all the watercolor  yeah that's it that's it  everything in there good match yeah yeah  well don't use your leg you could tip it  clock on there  now keep the cloth on top of that i  don't want you burning yourself yes on  right right and blend it nice and smooth  here we go